el coronavirus ha matado a más de 20
médicos en la paz durante enero los
galenos bolivianos ahora serán los
primeros en ser vacunados pero en lugar
de sentirse afortunados por la llegada
de un primer lote para la inmunización
de 10 mil médicos hay escepticismo
porque recibirán la vacuna sputnik 5
porque no dejan que venga otra
importadora y que tenga también 8
vacunas porque el gobierno solamente
quiere importar y todavía una vacuna que
entre comillas no saben su eficacia que
es lava con las rosas bolivia compro 5.2
millones de dosis de la sputnik 5 otras
5 millones más de las producidas por
astrazéneca y espera una donación de 5
millones adicionales de la cooperación
internacional sin embargo las vacunas
rusas han llegado primero y son las que
levantan polémica en las calles como
somos un país emergente dice mi país del
sur que ahora se utiliza ese término y
creen que pueden hacer experimentos con
nosotros
y creo que vamos a ser los conejillos de
indias no es posible que un gobierno no
proteja sus ciudadanos las vacunas rusas
han sido criticadas internacionalmente
porque son inoculadas en la población
sin cumplir con todas las etapas de su
desarrollo y por una falta de
transparencia sobre su eficacia
el gobierno boliviano además ha sido
criticado por la demora en una
vacunación a gran escala algo de lo que
culpa a la presidenta transitoria
jeanine áñez si el gobierno de facto se
hubiera ocupado de hacer lo que
correspondía en lugar de pretender
obtener ilegales beneficios económicos
para sus allegados ya estaríamos en este
momento aplicando las vacunas a nuestra
población como ocurre en otros países en
tanto a los bolivianos sólo les queda
esperar porque no tienen otra
alternativa para afrontar la pandemia